we now start our discussion of
stochastic processes by starting with
the simplest stochastic process there is
this is the so-called Bernoulli process
which is nothing but a sequence of
independent Bernoulli trials and we let
X I stand for the random variable that
describes the result in the trial the
assumptions that we make are that at
each trial there is a certain
probability P that the trial results in
1 and in that case we usually say that
there is a success at the eye trial and
the remaining probability 1 minus P is
assigned to the possibility that the
random variable X I takes a value of 0
in which case sometimes we say that
there was a failure now to keep things
non trivial we will always assume that P
is a number strictly between 0 and 1
because otherwise in the extreme cases
of P equal to 0 or P equal to 1 there
isn't really any randomness this process
is something that we have already seen
we have worked plenty of examples
involving repeated Bernoulli trials or
repeated coin flips we have solved
several problems we have seen several
formulas here we will recapitulate some
of them but we will also start looking
at the process from a new point of view
before continuing let me emphasize the
assumptions that come into the Bernoulli
process one key assumption is that we
have independence the different trials
are independent and the second
assumption that we make is that the
model is time homogeneous what I mean by
this is that this probability P of
success at a given trial is the same for
all trials it does not depend on I so
this process is as simple as a
stochastic process could be but
nevertheless it can be used as a model
in various situations sometimes it's
clear that we're dealing with a
Bernoulli process but sometimes it also
shows up in unexpected
in any case a first simple example could
be the following every week you play the
lottery and either you win or you do not
win and assuming that it is the same
kind of lottery that you play each week
the constant P would be the same the
probability of success and assuming a
lottery that is not rigged in any way
whether you win on one week should be
independent from what happens in other
weeks quite often the Bernoulli process
is used as a model of arrivals in which
case instead of saying probability of
success we would say probability of an
arrival the idea is that time is slotted
let's say in seconds for example and
each second you're sitting at the
entrance of a bank and you make a note
whether somebody came into the bank in
which case we have an arrival or success
or whether no one came during that time
interval if one here believes that
different slots different seconds are
independent of each other then you do
have a Bernoulli process it might not be
an exactly accurate model but it is a
good first approximation to start
working with a model of this situation
similarly if you have a server a
computer that takes jobs to process and
jobs are coming randomly you divide time
into slots and during each slot that job
might arrive or might not arrive and as
a first approach to a model of this kind
you might as well employ the Bernoulli
process the final note why is this
process called the Bernoulli process
well the name comes from a famous family
of Swiss mathematicians the Bernoulli
family and one of them Jacob Bernoulli
did many contributions to many branches
of mathematics but an important one was
in the field of probability where he
actually derived quite deep results on a
sequence of what we now call Bernoulli
trials